London is one of the world's great
cities how does it feel to be playing
here played every single event since
2010 so this will be my seventh and of
course I enjoy every single visit yeah
it's good to be back I've had a lot of
good results here some I'm looking
forward to the event yeah I've been to
many great places but of course London
is yeah the special place good to be
here I love playing in London it's a
beautiful place to play and when the
weather is so good can't complain it's
always great to be back in town and now
this is a huge event for me and also for
English chess in general yeah it's my
first time playing in London you know
it's a very prestigious thing for a
chess player to be able to play here
I'll be really important for me to do
well here I always like to play here so
for me it's always a pleasure to come
back and especially for this event which
is very well organized and has a very
special atmosphere so I'm very glad to
be here it's a great pleasure to come
back here I mean I was in London last
year I had a great time in general I
mean there's a lot of things to do in
London it's why I think my fourth time
playing in London so I'm I'm feeling
good it is a beautiful city
the weather is seasonably warm it's a
great tournament so I'm looking forward
to it knowing that I can for the win how
do you feel about your play coming into
the event no idea no idea I mean I had
quite a tough season so for one side I
feel I was playing pretty well recently
but another point of view well I had
quite quite many tournaments lately so I
bit worried about my physical it's a
shape I played reasonably well my raspy
last few events but you always keep your
fingers crossed I feel pretty confident
I've had a bunch of decent to good
results some very good results I mean we
won the Olympia which was fantastic
I've had a good run and then I basically
collapsed in two tournaments this year I
don't really know the reason you know
sometimes maybe you run out of some
emotional strength or or whatever it is
I would say that I played a little bit
too much and in like August in September
I think my result in the sink old cup
was was reasonable and then uh done in
the olimpiadas knild man I didn't play
so well but I've had a couple of months
off now so I feel pretty fresh and ready
to bring my best and hopefully things go
my way I've had a pretty long break from
classical chess but I feel confident I
mean it's gonna be a very tough
tournament you have all the strongest
players in the world except for Magnus
but it's it's fantastically strong but I
still think that I have a good chance to
win I've tried to prepare for the first
few games the advantages we knew the
pairings well in advance and so I think
at least in the first few rounds we'll
give the appearance of having looked at
just recently but in such a strong
tournament you never know how it goes it
can go well it can also go totally wrong
it's just too strong - to be sure that
at least you will have a you know good
decent level you never know this is a
very important event so it's a good
chance to kind of finish the year on a
positive note after you who do you think
is in the best form to potentially come
in second place be your greatest rival
that's that's a difficult question if I
had to pick someone I think I'd I think
I'd pick Vichy or Maxine let's go with
the rating guys Fabian fabulous we have
issue she probably is on on a high you
know I don't know well where's Lisa has
been doing pretty well on the Grand Tour
so fast perhaps he's a guy to watch out
for FA Fabiana I think the thing filled
gap yeah root for him let's say Fabiano
I would say that Aronian if I'm winning
and I would pick Aronian for a second
place let's say Kramnik but honestly if
I'm first in this tournament I don't
care at all the second